let's see a practical example where the
bar graph can be used to understand data
more easily
this is a graph of average temperature
of various cities
in this graph we mark 10 degrees in
equal intervals
and we have been given data for six
cities
a b
c d
e and f
now just by looking at this graph let's
try to answer a few questions
here's the first one
which is the hottest city among these
six cities
well it's obvious its city f as its
average temperature is highest among
peers
next one
if temperature greater than 25 degrees
celsius is warm
list the warm cities
this is the 25 degree celsius line
all cities having their average
temperature above this line will be
included in the list
so the warm cities are b c and f
here's the last one
what is the difference in temperatures
between the hottest and the coldest
cities
the temperature of the hottest city is
approximately 48 degrees celsius
and the temperature of the coldest city
is around 9 degrees celsius
so the answer is 48 minus 9 which will
equal 39 degrees celsius
apart from helping us answer such
questions the most important way in
which the bar graph helps us is that
just by looking at it we get an idea
about each of the categories
you